you joined me today in ancient greece
it's well it
doesn't look like this thank goodness
thanks um it's it's not not what you're
expecting but um it's a sixth century bc
and uh in particular we're on a greek
island just off the coast of turkey it's
called samos and
i know what you're thinking you'd like
to dig a tunnel through a mountain
wouldn't you
question is how on earth do you dig a
tunnel through a mountain when you don't
have access to any modern equipment
i'll tell you how you dig a tunnel
through a mountain okay so here is your
mountain
lovely now there are a couple of things
that you need to dig a tunnel through a
mountain you're going to need to have an
entrance and an exit those are
the two requisite components of a tunnel
so let's say you want to go in here
and you want to come out here
now the thing is is that you can't just
start digging in here and just
hope that you'll come out here it's not
gonna work right you need to make sure
that you hit the right bit so what
people tend to do this is what they did
for the channel tunnel for example
is you start digging here and you start
digging here and you just hope that they
line up
um except that i mean you you're
unlikely to find each other in the
middle of a mountain
so you need a technique to make sure
that these two lines end up meeting up
in the middle and the way that you do
that is by using triangles
i would have thought if you made
absolutely sure you were digging in a
straight line
you'd be all right
as long as you can always as long as you
look behind you and the whole
is still behind you yeah but the
straight line hang on if you were in a
straight line okay so let's imagine that
you let me do like a contour of this
mountain
it's quite a wobbly mountain this one so
you want to go in here and you want to
come out here the problem is that if you
dig in a straight line you could end up
over here
right so how do you make sure you make
sure that you get exactly there
and it's not like you can just stand on
the top of the mountain and you go
heading that way lads
you know what i mean because you can't
when you're standing over here you can't
see around there right so it's really
hard to even to even know i feel like in
the era of gps you could just do the
straight line in gps i think you
probably can i think you probably can
apart from the fact that you're in a
tunnel i don't think signals great in
tunnels but
if you start in a straight line and then
just keep looking behind you to make
sure that the hole's still there you
know you're going in a straight line
anyway
so you're saying the main problem is you
can't see the other side you can't see
where you're going yeah exactly
so the way that you do this
it's very neat
so you try and walk around from one side
of the mountain to the other and as you
go you want to try and stay at the same
level as you go around every time you
take a step south you add it up every
time you take a step to the
west you add up and you're very careful
about how big all of your steps are as
you're going
maybe you do this twice just to make
sure you've got the right numbers you've
done it all in units and right angles
and you've been really careful all the
way along because even in ancient greece
you can imagine it'd be quite easy to
construct a right angle wouldn't be too
difficult but in total then imagine that
you have taken 84 steps west and you
have taken 13 steps south so effectively
then to get the direction from one place
to the other you are talking about a
triangle
with those as the sides so you know it's
going to be 84 along there and 13 along
there and you know that that's a right
angle because you've only ever walked
south and west and so you have this very
nice neat triangle i deliberately chose
one that was a pythagorean triple you're
welcome
so this is 85.
so now actually when you are at the
entrance to each of these tunnels
you can construct a much smaller version
of the same triangle and build it here
and if you make a kind of really long
rod to sort of extend that angle and you
do the same thing over here so you've
got another version of the triangle here
then you should have
these two lines these two angles that
will meet really perfectly in the middle
so the only thing you've got to be
careful of now
is when you're digging
to make sure that you stay perfectly
flat you don't want to go up you don't
want to go down
and the way that they do that is that
they put water in the tunnel
and then as they're digging they make
sure that the water just sits nice and
still rather than dripping in one
direction or the other like a spirit
level like a spirit level exactly this
particular mountain this is uh samos and
this was in 525 bc
polar crates i don't think it's called
boycott
how do you pronounce
polygraphs
holy cookies oh
it's polly cruties whatever polly crates
he wanted a tunnel
you should you can shoot police he
wanted this tunnel it's a kilometer long
525 bc this is built and this is exactly
the technique that archaeologists think
that they used
and when they did so they did incredibly
well there was a tiny bit of zigzagging
at one end and they think it was because
they were trying to work their way
around some quite difficult rock but
then they re-established this sort of
plum line as it were and when these two
tunnels mess middle there's like a tiny
little step of 60 centimeters it's like
this unbelievably remarkable achievement
with just some triangles
how do you know where to put those
triangles so the triangles are at the
right that's got to be a line that runs
exactly
east to west and that's got to be a line
that runs exactly north to south
do they have compasses
i'm assuming they had compasses well
they knew they had the sun they had the
sun yeah yeah that's true you're
open and close to the tunnel they
actually need to be at the same level
before you start you know the one
altitude yeah the same masters exactly
your water thing wouldn't work if you
had one of your if you're like yeah yeah
let's start there and you hadn't worked
out that actually one was much more
uphill than the other now this is
something they're not quite sure about
how they did it how they managed it but
there is some suggestion i think it's
i'm not convinced by this but there's
some suggestions some archaeologists
think that created this tower and then
got a massive long stick
i mean
maybe i haven't understood this quite
right but my understanding of it is they
went up to the top of the tower and then
they dangled a big long stick down and
then they sort of swung it around the
mountain so they were like oh there you
go that's a nice point right there well
you could use a rope for that actually
and make it straight yeah like toured
although it's pretty hard to keep a rope
that long taut yeah it's like a
kilometer
but i don't think they built a kilometer
long stick either
anyway some mysteries remain unsolved
shall we say
this episode was supported by brilliant
loving creators of puzzles and courses
like these
brilliants all about interaction getting
you to move things around click and
think
slide things into place that's the key
to understanding really engaging with
what you're learning
check out their huge and ever growing
library of material at brilliant.org
slash number file using that slash
number file will bag you a 20 discount
on their premium subscription by the way
and if you're looking for that something
special for the learner in your life you
can also give a brilliant subscription
as a gift check them out
brilliant.org
number five
there's a certain type of lizards that
use um
uh well the way that the males dominate
one another follows a rock paper
scissors type game there's the orange
lizards
these are the guys they're called ultra
dominant right they've got big
territories they've got loads of females
they're the big guys right